في كوريا الشماليه ان يحكم عليك بالاعدام
او الاشغال الشاقه احتمال وارد جدا لجميع
افراد الشعب فغفوه قصيره خلال تجمع يحضره
هذا الرجل تعني نهايه حياتك بمدفع مضاد
للطائرات وان فكرت يوما في الهروب من هذا
الجحيم واللجوء الى بلد اخر قد يطبق عليك
قانون يدعى ثلاثه اجيال من العقوبه
تعالوا معنا لنتعرف على قصه جديده من عالم
غريب
[موسيقى]
في كوريا الشماليه البلد الاكثر انعزاليه
على مستوى العالم هناك قوانين لا تتواجد
في دوله سواها محاذير عديده ان فعلتها
تقلب حياتك راسا على عقب السجن والاعمال
الشاقه وربما الاعدام في ساحه عامه امام
انظار الجميع
فابتسامه في غير موضعها او ارتداء الجنس
او حتى حلق شعر الراس دون الالتزام بالقصه
التي تقرها الحكومه
تعرض اصحابها لعقوبات قاسيه اما اجراء
مكالمه هاتفيه دوليه خارج كوريا الشماليه
فيعني الاعدام لا محاله مكالمه قد تكلفك
حياتك
في اكتوبر من عام 2007 وامام 150 الف
متفرجا في مقاطعه بوينجان الجنوبيه اعظم
مدير احد المصانع رميا بالرصاص والجريمه
التي ارتكبها هي اجراء مكالمه هاتفيه
دوليه وحيازته 13 هاتفا في قبول مصنعه
كوريا الشماليه لديها ايضا شبكه انترنت
خاصه بها تدعى شبكه
اما الانترنت المتعارف عليه فيقتصر على
بعض الساسه والمسؤولين اما اذا كنت سائحا
واردت معرفه تفاصيل اي شيء هناك فلن يجيبك
احد فعند سؤالك احد المرات دون حمل تصريح
حكومي بالتحدث مع المواطنين
سيفر الكوري الشمالي من كسريعا
التحدث والتصوير هناك ممنوعان بنص القانون
لكن الضربه القاضيه هي محاوله التقاط صوره
او حتى الاحتفاظ بملصق لزعيم كيم جونغ اون
قبل سنوات تم القبض على طالب جامعي امريكي
بتهمه محاولته سرقه ملصق دعائي سياسي من
فندقه في بيون جانج الطالب الامريكي اعتذر
باكيا لكنه عقب بالسجن 15 عاما مع الاشغال
الشاقه
وقف هذا الطالب باكيا راجيا العفو من
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي لكن بلا جدوى وفي
النهايه سجن الطالب بضع سنوات ثم ارسل
للولايات المتحده ومتى بعدها بمرض نادر في
الدماغ وفي عام 2014 سجن الاميركي لمده
خمسه اشهر لانه كان يحمل نسخه من الكتاب
المقدس فكوريا الشماليه ملحده رسميا بنص
القانون ولا تعترف باي شعائر دينيه الولاء
هنا فقط لزعيم
لدرجه انه في يوم الثامن من يوليو من كل
عام يتوجب ان يحزن الشعب الكوري باكمله
وهو يوم يوافق الذكرى السنويه لوفاه كيم
الساون جد الرئيس الحالي لكوريا الشماليه
ومن يضحك في هذا اليوم قد يواجه الاعتقال
وربما الاعدام
[تصفيق]
الهفوات البسيطه في كوريا الشماليه قد
تاخذ الشخص لمصير مجهول لذا فكر بعض
الكوريين الشماليين في الهروب لكن هذا
الخيار ايضا ليس سهلا فكيف يعبر من هذه
الاسوار المحصنه وان نجح في العبور
والهروب فعليه نسيان بقيه اهله لان قانون
ثلاثه اجيال من العقوبه الذي صنع عام 1950
سيطبق على اسرته فورا اي ان اطفال الشخص
الهارب واحفاده من بعده سيسجنون مدى
الحياه وتصبح دمائهم مذنبا على حد وصف
السلطات هناك